effacée par la pression à travers l'art
et la pression ainsi sortis pour passer
par cette frontière est donc il faudra
du temps autrement dit autrement dit
pour des petites valeurs
ce n'est pas une manifestation
dans ce pays qu'on croyait jamais par la
pluie
je suis un berlinois disette en 1963 le
président teddy face au mur de berlin en
pleine guerre froide
depuis les une norme atx est et la carte
de l'europe dessinée à yalta jeu ni de
jour en jour désormais elle est déchirée
la décision du gouvernement est-allemand
fait exploser un peu plus la notion de
bloc de neige le mur de berlin érigé
dans le secret d'une 1961 le 13 symbole
de l'affrontement est ouest n'existe
plus alors que pendant des années pour
certains il n'y avait pas de fuir à tout
prix par contre le fascisme pour les
murs de la route pour les autres 28 ans
après son édification
il va devenir une pièce du musée de la
guerre froide
plusieurs centaines d'allemands ils sont
mort fusillé par les gardes frontières
de l'est encore au début de cette année
c'est dire le pas il vient d'être
tranché
tendrement du mur de berlin précisément
comme tout se précipite dans ce pays que
l'on croyait à jamais figé dans un
stalinisme nostalgique il y a trois
semaines trois semaines seulement
qu'eric à necker a dû quitter le pouvoir
poussé dehors par gorbatchev et aussi
par la pression de la rue qui timidement
aux est manifestée et bien aujourd'hui
la rue dicte sa politique au régime et
face d'une certaine manière
28 ans d'histoire et d'une histoire
douloureuse
philippe lefait je suis un berlinois
disait en 1963 le président kennedy face
au mur de berlin nous étions en pleine
guerre froide
depuis les urban chef et la carte de
l'europe dessinée à yalta jeu ni de jour
en jour désormais elle est déchirée
la décision du gouvernement est-allemand
fait exploser un peu plus la notion de
bloc de l'est
le mur de berlin édifié dans le secret
d'une nuit d'où 1961 le 13
symbole de l'affrontement est ouest
n'existe plus alors que pendant des
années pour certains il avait fallu fuir
à tout prix rempart contre le fascisme
pour les un mur de la honte pour les
autres 28 ans après son édification il
va devenir une pièce du musée de la
guerre froide
plusieurs centaines d'allemands ils sont
mort fusillé par les gardes frontières
de l'est encore au début de cette année
c'est dire le pas qui vient d'être
franchi